it's so funny man i was i was talking to
uh
to phil about this last night and i'm
like you know he was talking about jake
paul and i'm like this is the future
this is this is not an anomaly
it's you get an x amount of people doing
prank videos then you become a a music
artist and you get an x amount of people
doing that and then you do
a podcast you get an x amount of people
doing that you look up you've got a
couple million followers you can do
whatever you want i'm gonna be a boxer
no you're not well there's four million
people willing to watch me that says i
can box
jake buddy come let's have a fight yeah
get a marketplace first talking about
jake paul here's what jake paul just
said yesterday i don't know if you guys
saw that or not jake paul
said claims he and his brother logan
paul will run for president when they
turn 35 years old after youtube unboxing
careers this is a sun story
jake 24 years old logan 26 years old
will
run for president 2032 during an
interview with overtime jake was asked
who would be more likely to become a u.s
president out of himself or l.a
laker superstar lebron james and even
though he admitted the basketball
would be more likely to be voted into
the white house he then announced
his intention to run for president when
he turned 35 years old says i'm running
for president
uh but i'm not even 35 yet my brother
and i would run for president 2032
that's when we're eligible we're still
figuring this thing out i might be
president he might be president i think
we're going to flip a coin and see who
gets to be the president versus who's vp
by the way
i've been saying this for a while that i
think the paul's one of them is going to
be the president i think more likely
either one of them has enough audacity
to do it uh
but i think eventually one of these guys
going to be the president can you see a
president paul you know
why not tom can you see that happening
the the
the value of followership influence for
paul to become a president
um you know when is a celebrity
um ever like made it to like a major
political
office well actually except that
wrestler that became
governor of minnesota that's right um oh
yeah and um
schwarzenegger became governor of
california oh crap it could happen
how about the actor who became a uh uh
uh president two-term and then the other
guy who had a show for 15 years
apprentice that became a president so so
is it inevitable that one of these guys
going to be a president
there there there you go again i always
felt that i was destined to lead this
country that's more reagan than the
other one was obama by the way the other
one was kind of like elvis presley when
i was thinking about it
i got it for obama i got to smoke a pack
of salems and get the rough voice oh
really
did he smoke salem or no dude
obama secretly no no no not obama reagan
was reagan a smoker i don't know if
reagan was a smoker early on he was in
all the celebrities everybody was
smoking cigarettes back in the days man
you know dude like this is this is one
of those things like
we're a democratic republic i get it but
man oh man man like
some there's something sometimes where
i'm just like we we kind of should just
go back to like
a council of elders like let's let's
just have a council of elders let's get
like a couple of uh
a couple of oligarchs together and hope
we get the right ones man because like
look give them a podcast let's go for it
man like
you know this one of the one of the
great things about our government
is that they they they force us to
believe that they actually doing
something this entire all of congress
can be done like
tinder we could all have we could all
have votes on our phone every day and
just right swipe or left swipe
we can do all their jobs from our phone
man so i who knows dude
who knows look do you think jake and
logan paul
would be good presidents i bet you
they'd probably be better than than
people would think because again they're
so egocentric
and they're so legacy dependent they
would probably get really good people
around them
to implement some some things i i don't
i don't know i i
i would i would love to see that
campaign though i have to be honest
i don't know if i want to live in a
world where jake paul is
my president but i definitely want to
live in a world where jake paul is
running for president
for sure how does it look like is it
troll county
nonstop nonstop troll county
he just i'd knock you out you know would
it be that kind of an environment
or he steals somebody's tie in the
middle of the debate and then runs
around the auditorium
[Laughter]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye